hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
captivating works of beetle The Bard
specifically we're going to be diving
into who Beetle was what lessons his
stories teach what they're about and how
his stories have so effectively managed
to stand the test of time within the
realm of Harry Potter Beatle The Bard is
a renowned author whose stories have
been cherished by generations of witches
and wizards his collection of magical
fables aptly titled the tales of beetle
The Bard holds a special place in the
hearts of fans worldwide you've never
heard of the tales of beetle The Bard
Ron asked Hermione incredulously in
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
this just about sums up why the tales
are so special for centuries the fables
have been the staple of Wizarding
childhoods the sound of bedtime stories
to children who grew up in Wizarding
families the hopping pot in the fountain
of fair Fortune are as familiar to them
as Cinderella and Sleeping Beauty are to
muggle children Beatles Tales provide us
with delightful glimpses into the rich
folklore The Wizarding World As We
explore his works let us not only Marvel
the Magic in Wonder encapsulated Within
These Timeless stories but also reflect
on the wisdom they impart each of these
Tales offer a wealth of knowledge and
understanding presenting us with
valuable life lessons and
thought-provoking dilemmas to
contemplate without further Ado let's
dive into it are they fairy tales the
first thing I want to address is whether
or not Beetle stories can be considered
fairy tales in the Muckle World fairy
tales are traditional stories that have
been passed down through generations
often originating from oral traditions
and later being recorded and adapted
into written form these Tales typically
feature Magical elements enchanting
creatures and and moral lessons but in a
world where magic is interwoven into the
fabric of reality do fairy tales still
exist it's fascinating to ponder if
fairy tales can exist in a world where
magic is so ever present in many ways
Beatles stories do share similarities
with our traditional fairy tales they
embrace the notion of virtue being
rewarded and wickedness being punished
just like the tales we grew up with
histories also offer valuable lessons
for children to unravel and discuss with
their parents as far as the magic thing
perhaps it's possible that the true
magic of a fairy tale lies not in the
literal spells and enchantments but in
the power of the words and the
imagination of the writer if this is the
case perhaps Beetle's stories are not so
different from fairy tales after all as
long as the words transport you to a
place of Wonder and Magic whether there
are explicitly described spells or not
the essence of a fairytale L remains
perhaps this is a good time to bring up
the wise words of Albus Dumbledore of
course it is happening inside your head
Harry but why on Earth should that mean
that it is not real the magic of a tale
whether it be through a magical world
with Wizards and witches or a
traditional fairy tale Castle is very
much alive and real within our
imaginations who was Beetle The Bard
Beetle the bond the Beloved Storyteller
of The Wizarding World has left an
indelible mark on magical literature
while much of his life remains shrouded
in mystery we do know a few details
about this enigmatic figure
according to historical accounts Beetle
de Bard was a wizard who lived in the
15th century born in Yorkshire England
his birth name and exact birth date are
unknown however we do know that he
possessed exceptional storytelling
skills and had an exceptionally
luxuriant beard as shown in the
surviving wood cut that depicts him
Beatle The Bard's claim to fame lies in
his collection of fairy tales aptly
titled the tales of beetle The Bard
these enchanting Tales Encompass a
variety of themes from the pursuit of
power to the importance of love and
sacrifice aside from his facial hair
it's impossible to truly know Beetle but
perhaps we can catch a glimpse of him in
his stories a wizard who is sympathetic
to Muggles mistrusted dark magic and
believed that kindness common sense and
Ingenuity were more admirable than even
the most powerful magic it's worth
noting that the tales of beetle The Bard
have not only entertain generations of
witches and wizards but also provide
valuable moral lessons and insights into
the Wizarding World many Wizards and
witches grew up hearing these Tales
which were passed down from one
generation to another subsequently
adding to the rich tapestry of magical
law Beatles stories within the pages of
Beatles Tales there lies a tapestry of
wisdom and insight subtly woven into
captivating narratives that span the
breadth of human emotions each tale
invites us to reflect on the choices we
make the power of love and sacrifice and
the consequences of succumbing to the
Allure of power themes consistent within
the greater story of Harry Potter Albus
Dumbledore once said words are and my
not so humble opinion are most
inexhaustible source of magic so let the
magic of Beatles Tales ignite your
imagination and let's dive into some of
his most popular stories unfortunate
Patiently I can't provide you with the
entire stories and the summaries so if
you want the full versions be sure to
grab a copy online or at your local
Bookshop without further Ado let's dive
into five of beetle The Bard Stories the
wizard and the hopping pot this story
revolves around a kind-hearted old
wizard who used his magic to help the
Muggles of his village
to avoid revealing his Wizarding
abilities he cleverly disguised his
magic as wondrous medicines brewed in an
old cauldron however one day the old
wizard died and upon his passing the
wizard bestowed his only son with all
his belongings including the mysterious
pot unfortunately the sun possessed none
of his father's kindness or magical
skills feeling little to no generosity
or sympathy when it came to Muggles
after his father's death the son found
the pots and a single slipper inside it
together with a note from his father
that read in the fond hope my son that
you will never need this bitter for
having been left nothing but a pot the
sun began turning away every person who
sought his help closing his door to the
cries of those in need the first person
that the sun closed his door on was an
old woman whose granddaughter was
planked with Wards after the sun shut
the door on the old woman a strange
clacking sound emerged from the kitchen
and when the sun went to investigate he
saw that the part had grown afoot with
warts of its own the next to seek the
sun's aide was an old man whose donkey
was lost but the sun turned him away too
only for the pot to start making donkey
like sounds
the next visitor was a young woman who
was hoping to find a cure for her sick
baby
over time the sun continued to get
visitor after visitor despite his
refusal to help the people of his
village eventually however he gave in
calling upon all of his neighbors to
finally offer them help with each
request he fulfilled the pot slowly
emptied until at last out popped a
mysterious leper that perfectly fit the
foot of the now silent pods together
they sorted off into the sunset
the wizard in the hopping pot reminds
readers of the importance of
selflessness kindness and using one's
talents to benefit others it teaches us
the act of helping and caring for others
is not just a responsibility but also a
source of personal growth and
fulfillment in an interview JK Rowling
explained that wizard in the hopping pot
is kind of moral really it's to teach
young witches and wizards that they
should be using their magic
altruistically the Fountain of fair
Fortune the Fountain of fair Fortune is
a story about three witches and a knight
who journey to a magical fountain in the
hope of finding a cure for their
personal hardships
picture a secluded Garden veiled in
strong magic where once a year an
unfortunate is given the chance to bathe
in its Waters and win fair Fortune
forevermore people from all corners of
the Kingdom flocked to this Garden
desperate to transform their lives among
them were three witches each carrying
their own heavy burdens Asia sick of a
malady no healer could cure hope the
fountain would restore her health all
theater robbed and humiliated by a
sorcerer sought Solace from her
helplessness and poverty and amasa
abandoned by her beloved hoped the
fountain would help cure her grief and
longing realizing the power of unity the
three witches joined forces in their
quest in a twist of fate they found
themselves Tangled together with a
hapless muggle Knight as they passed
through the garden's magical barrier
only one of them would be allowed to
bathe in the fountain and the first two
witches were initially dismayed by the
extra competition but soon they
discovered that the Knight named sir
luckless for good reason was filled with
bravery and a sense of adventure
together they faced three challenges on
their Journey first a monstrous white
worm bloated in blind who demanded the
proof of your pain it was only through
Asia's tears of frustration that they
managed to satisfy the creature and
progress next they encountered a steep
slope that demanded the fruit of their
labors after numerous failed attempts it
was althea's perseverance and hard work
that finally LED them forward lastly
they encountered a stream that asked for
The Treasure of your past despite their
efforts it seemed impossible to cross
however a Masa had a brilliant idea to
use her wand to withdraw the memories of
her cruel and faithless lover turning
them into stepping stones that carried
them to the Fountain but when they
finally reached the fountain Asia's
exhaustion and near-death State
prevented her from reaching it in a
surprising turn of events all theda's
quick thinking and a powerful potion she
brewed miraculously cured Asia's malady
no longer needing the fountain's waters
all Theda realized her own power to heal
others and Escape her own powerlessness
and poverty
similarly amata once she realized her
regrets and saw her Lover's true nature
no longer needed the fountain's waters
she generously offered her turn to Sir
luckless as a reward for his bravery
overwhelmed with newfound luck the night
bathed in the fountain and then humbly
pledged himself to a martyr recognizing
her as a woman worthy of his love and
devotion each witch achieved their
dreams for a cure a hapless night one
knowledge of his bravery and abata the
one which had faith in him realized that
she had found a man worthy of her the
four new friends set off arm and arm and
ended up living out long happy lives the
Fountain of fair Fortune teaches the
importance of empathy friendship and
perseverance in overcoming challenges it
emphasizes the power of unity and
selflessness in finding happiness and
achieving personal growth a small fun
fact about this story Lucius Malfoy once
attempted to have story centered at
Hogwarts because of its depiction of
marriage between a witch and a muggle
fortunately Dumbledore promptly refused
lucius's request the warlock's hairy
heart in The Haunting tale of the
warlock's hairy heart we encounter a
handsome and affluent young warlock who
fearing the vulnerabilities of Love
turns to dark magic he Revels in the
belief that his self-imposed isolation
is admired until he overhears his
servants discussing his lack of a wife
dealing a bruising blow to his pride
driven by a desire to be envied the
Warlock embarks in a quest to find a
beautiful and Wealthy Maiden Fortune
Smiles upon him the next day when he
encounters a woman who is both
fascinated and repelled by him after
persuading her and her family to join
him for a lavish Feast the Warlock
attempts to win her affections borrowing
words from a poet to impress her however
the maiden challenge him insisting on
proof of his heart's existence
reluctantly he takes her to the Castle's
dungeon unveiling his own withered hairy
heart and snared in an enchanted Crystal
casket you see due to its long
separation from his body the heart has
withered and become covered in black
hair worried for his well-being the
maiden implores the Warlock to return
his heart to its rightful place which he
does Overjoyed she Embraces him yet the
extended separation and exposure to dark
magic have transformed his heart into a
Savage uncontrollable Force this
malevolent Force compels the Warlock to
resort to Extreme Measures to obtain a
genuinely human heart in his pursuit of
Greater magical power he tears out the
heart of the young Maiden intending to
replace his own however his heart proves
too resilient resisting the stolen
heart's influence rendering his magic
few futile determined not to be enslaved
by his own Hearts dark desires he makes
a harrowing decision and removes his own
heart from his chest tragically he
perishes clutching one heart in each
hand lying beside the lifeless body of
the Maiden The warlock's Hairy heart
serves as a cautionary tale reminding us
of the fundamental importance of love
and connection it warns against shutting
oneself off from the world for in doing
so we risk losing our humanity and
becoming consumed by darkness babati
rabbiti and her cackling stump in the
land far away there was a king who
desired all of the Magic in the world
for himself however in order to gather
all of the magic he realized that he
would first have to gather all of the
witches and wizards in the world
prompting him to form the Brigade of
witch Hunters
but before he could do this he needed to
learn how to use magic himself which led
to his search for someone with magical
abilities who could teach him no genuine
witches or Wizards responded to his call
but one person did a muggle who
pretended to know magic the Muggle armed
with a handful of clever tricks manages
to impress the king and gain his trust
as his confidence grows he begins to
request precious jewelry and money in
exchange for further teachings however
little did he know that babati the
humble Washerwoman in the King's Service
was keeping a watchful eye
one day the king and the Muggle
overheard babati laughing hysterically
during one of their practices this
enraged the king who demanded that the
Muggle helped him perform in front of
his subjects to show off his new
abilities the Muggle makes up excuse
after excuse to try and get out of it
but the king insists unsure of what to
do next the Muggle travels to bavity's
Cottage where he discovers that she's a
real wench following this he blackmails
her to help assist in tricking the king
they eventually agree that the best way
to trick the king would be to have
bavity hide in a bush making it seem as
though the king himself is performing
the magic during the performance the
crowd is Amazed by the various tricks
but when asked to raise the Dead the
king fails as babasi knows that such
magic is impossible the Muggle then
points at bamity in the bush and
explains that a wicked witch had been
blocking his magic babati then flees
into a forest and disappears at the base
of an old tree in desperation the Muggle
makes the Bold Proclamation that babati
has turned into a tree and calls for the
tree to get cut down as the crowd
departs the stump of the tree starts
cackling explaining that real Wizards
and witches can't be cut in half
to prove her Point she then suggests
that they should cut the Muggle in half
to prove it this of course prompts the
Muggle to finally confess that he's a
fraud but here's where it gets juicy
bapati then reveals that the king is
cursed and that he will feel the stroke
of an ax every time a witch or wizard is
harmed in response to this the king
makes a proclamation declaring that
witches and wizards are protected and
that they must not be harmed but that
wasn't enough for babati she also
demanded that the statue be built of
herself to remind everyone of what had
been decreed the king vowed to fulfill
her request and even went a step further
by erecting a statue of her made of gold
at the end of the story an old rabbit
emerged from a hole in the stump that
the statue was to be placed on revealing
that babati had been hiding in her
animagus form all along from that day on
the Statue of babati remained on top of
the stump serving as a reminder that no
witch or wizard should ever be harmed in
that Kingdom again JK Rowling had this
to say babati rapity and her cackling
stump is the stupidest title ever
written by man or beast and of course
when I wrote it I never I had not at the
point when I gave Ron that title I
didn't imagine for a second that I was
actually going to write the story but I
did get there and it's a story about
revenge one witch's sort of cunning way
of revenging herself for persecution for
muggle persecution the tale of the Three
Brothers you will know this one so I
won't go into too much detail this tale
tells the story of three wizard brothers
who come across a treacherous River on
their travels they use their magical
abilities to conjure up a bridge that
are confronted by death who is unhappy
that they have cheated him of his
potential victims death under the guise
of congratulating them presents them
with gifts the first brother asks for a
wand more powerful than any other the
second asks for a stone that can bring
back the dead and the third asks for a
cloak of invisibility that will shield
him from death's gaze
the brothers received their gifts and go
their separate ways but come to realize
that their new powers are not without
consequences the first brother is
eventually killed by a thief who steals
his all-powerful wand the second brother
unable to accept the things he can't
change dies after using the stone to
bring back his lost love and the third
brother who uses his cloak to avoid
death until old age leaves the world a
peaceful and happy man the story teaches
readers about the dangers of meddling
with death and that in the end death is
an inevitable part of life it also
highlights the importance of humility
and acceptance of one's fate are these
stories real while reading Beatles Tales
I found myself asking one question over
and over are these stories real within
Harry Potter anyway based on the
available information this is a
difficult question to answer these
stories are presented as a part of the
Wizarding world's folklore and no not
much is known about their Origins
however there is one clue in the Harry
Potter story which leads me to believe
that there is some semblance of Truth to
his tales at least to one of them in
Harry Potter we come to understand that
the three Deathly Hallows the Elder Wand
Resurrection Stone and invisibility
cloak do genuinely exist provided that
these artifacts also exist in Beetle's
tale I think there are a few different
possibilities the first is these stories
did genuinely occur with Beetle bearing
witness 2 or perhaps just hearing about
each and every one of them in this
scenario Beatles stories would simply
directly represent real-life events that
occurred the next is that Beatles simply
heard about similar stories or new of
magical objects like the Deathly Hallows
and built a narrative around them
there's little evidence to support
either argument that the stories were
fabricated entirely or that beatled Drew
inspiration from something that he had
witnessed in his life however given that
the Hallows actually exist I'm willing
to bet that it was the latter officially
the tales of beetle The Bard continually
reinforced that the stories are in fact
the author's original Creations however
that certainly doesn't mean that beedle
did not draw inspiration from his
real-life experiences the things that he
had done or the people that he had met
we also know that claims like this don't
always turn out to have much value Q
gilderoy Lockhart
JK Rowling supplies the following
forward to Beatle The Bard's bug if his
stories accurately reflect his opinions
he rather liked Muggles whom he regarded
as ignorant rather than malevolent he
mistrusted dark magic and he believed
that the worst excesses of wizard kind
sprang from the all too human traits of
Cruelty apathy or arrogant
misapplication of their own talents the
heroes and heroines who Triumph in his
stories are not those with the most
powerful magic but rather those who
demonstrate the most kindness common
sense and Ingenuity but whether they're
real or not I think it's safe to say
that the tales of beetle The Bard have
made their Mark in Wizarding history and
positively impacted Wizarding culture
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please be sure to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember words are in my
not so humble opinion are most
inexhaustible source of magic
[Music]
foreign